well if you haven't got anything else to
do you better do it now because this is
not going to be very hot I I bring you
know very great news I'm not I'm not
winning anything I'm not passionately
out but I've had the time of my life
died tonight this is the greatest show
that's ever been put on
so I'm going to put my glasses on
because it can't see and I want to thank
you very much for that for that really
you know it really is a wonderful life
and it's a wonderful business I still
get goose pimples when I see good movies
and I even get more boosted that don't
dimple pimples when I think that the
eASIC at these Academy Awards are seen
in every part of the world think of it I
think he said 500 million of people
watching what we do isn't that a
challenge and the rarest part and a
responsibility I think it is and so does
this wonderful Academy and now the five
nominees for the best picture of the
year are the Big Chill sixties ideals
coming face to face with the realities
of the 80s after a young man takes his
own life
a Carson Productions group production
Columbia Michael Schamberg producer the
dresser a Shakespearean during a Korean
company holds fast to its love of
language and traditions of acting in the
England of World War two a gold crash
films world film services production
columbia peter yates producer
the right stuff the story of America's
that reach into the space program of our
first seven astronauts and their early
successes and failures a Robert Sharks
off
Irwin Winkler production the land
company through Warner Brothers tender
mercies an out of luck country singer in
Texas finds a second chance for love for
family and for his music an EMI
presentation of an answer on medium
production Universal AFD Philip s hobo
producer terms of endearment 30 years in
the lives of a mother and daughter 30
years of the bitter and sweet a James L
Brooks production paramount James L
Brooks producer and the winner is
that's nice event the winner is turn
this this community it took a long time
to get the picture made and this
community has been generous to this
picture from long before it was made
when we were trying to get it done I
want to acknowledge my co-producer is
penny Finkelman and Martin Giroux my
friends weren't failing through this
thing because it was it was a it was
their it was a kind of experience where
you went - you went to made it without
your friends I want to tell you the
Debra Winger worked on this picture in
countless ways for about a year with as
much as a person can give to a picture
there was a lot about you know every
studio turning it down I think it's much
more significant that a Hollywood studio
made it and that Hollywood studio was
flexible and that the studio ended up
happy that it made it I think that's
significant - that there was an audience
for this picture
I want to thank Barry Diller and Michael
Eisner Frank Mancuso Jeff Katzenberg and
Larry Marx and this isn't this is an
extraordinary evening for us there's no
way to express the gratitude thank you
very much